bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
consacré aux élections américaines au
lendemain du scrutin des mitormes la
vague rouge n'a pas eu lieu les
républicains sont certes majoritaires à
la Chambre des Représentants mais les
cas et d'une vingtaine de sièges et au
Sénat pour le moment c'est à égalité
quelques résultats à marquants
d'ailleurs pour le Sénat avec en
Pennsylvanie le démocrate John Salomone
qui a gagné face aux républicain même
être ose dans l'Ohio c'est le
républicain du dévers qui l'a emporté et
en Géorgie il y aura un second tour au
mois de décembre à second tour qui sera
donc déterminant pour justement
déterminer la couleur de la chambre
haute côté gouverneur la réélection de
ronde de Santis comme gouverneur de
Floride est à noter lui qu'on dit être
le challenger potentiel de Donald Trump
au sein du parti républicains alors
qu'elles enseignements peut-on tirer de
ce scrutin comment les démocrates
ont-ils résisté que révèle finalement
ses résultats de la société américaine
le trumpisme est-il dominant chez les
républicains et montre-t-il ses limites
quelle sera la marge de manœuvre de Joe
Biden en politique étrangère et
économique le président démocrate se
met-il en route pour 2024 Trump
prendra-t-il sa revanche et bien on va
poser toutes ces questions à mes invités
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
Cécile coquet mococo bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous professeur de
civilisation américaine à l'université
Versailles 50 ans en face de vous
Alexandre Mendel bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste des États-Unis
auteur de chez Trump 245 jours et 28
miles 28000 miles dans cet Amérique que
les médias
ignorent c'est aux éditions de
l'artilleur bienvenue à vous également
Dominique Moïse bonsoir géopolitologue
également conseillé spécial à l'Institut
montagne et membre fondateurs de l'IFRI
nous avons avec nous en direct de
Washington Christian anley Christian
Hanley consultant politique auprès du
Parti démocrate bonsoir à vous
bonsoir
pas de wagons je le disais les
républicains l'emportent à la Chambre
des représentants d'une vingtaine de
sièges et pour le Sénat ce n'est plus
seulement très serré c'est à égalité
pour le moment en tout cas on fait un
point en images avec Huguette de France
Télévisions
c'est une nuit électorale incertaine
palpitante que viennent de vivre les
Américains avec des résultats moins
mauvais qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour le
camp de Joe Biden
première à s'exprimer à 22h heure locale
Donald Trump entouré de ses supporters
dans sa résidence de Mara Lago l'ancien
président se montre triomphalys alors
même que très peu de résultats sont
tombés
les chiffres jusqu'à présent sont
géniaux il ne s'agit que de jusqu'à
présent nous en sommes à 80 victoires et
3 défaites est-ce que c'est pas génial
des accents victorieux démentis par les
résultats les télévisions donnent une
courte majorité pour les républicains à
la Chambre des Représentants et
inégalité parfaite au Sénat plus
ennuyeux encore pour Donald Trump large
victoire de cet homme en Floride run De
Santis arrivent à le potentiel pour la
présidentielle nous avons plus que ce
que quiconque aurait cru possible mais
il nous reste encore temps à faire et je
ne fais que commencer à me battre
plusieurs étapes les comme ici la
Pennsylvanie que les sondages voyaient à
qui à ce républicain proche de Trump
sont tombés dans l'escarcel démocrate
une victoire à l'arrachée pour ce futur
sénateur victime d'un avc
et dont les capacités avaient été mises
en doute
[Applaudissements]
je ne m'attendais pas à ce que nous
puissions gagner des circonscriptions
conservatrices mais nous avons fait ce
que nous devions faire à cette heure le
suspense reste entier pour le contrôle
du Sénat quatre sièges restent à
attribuer le comptage des voies pourrait
prendre plusieurs jours
la direction tout de suite la Géorgie on
retrouve Julie dungelhov notre envoyé
spécial on sait que la Géorgie et du
coup un état clé puisqu'il va y avoir un
second tour pour le Sénat Julie
oui tout à fait et second tour pourrait
déterminer le contrôle du Sénat alors
pourquoi en Géorgie y a-t-il un second
tour c'est parce qu'il y a une loi
électorale qui prévoit que pour
l'emporter il faut avoir plus de 50 %
des voix et ici en Géorgie il y avait un
troisième candidat dont
Julie je crois qu'on a un petit problème
de son malheureusement vous retrouverez
peut-être un petit peu plus tard
Christian anley vous êtes en direct avec
nous de Washington je vais tout de suite
vers vous vous êtes faites partie des
démocrates cette vague rouge finalement
n'a pas eu lieu contrairement à ce que
disait les sondages comment expliquer
cette résistance des démocrates
et bien comme vous venez de dire il y
avait pas de vagues rouges heureusement
et ça indique à la fois deux choses la
première chose c'est que le système de
développer de d'avoir des sondages dans
ce pays ne marche vraiment plus en fait
les sondages qu'on a dans notre système
aux États-Unis dépendent des
téléphones à la maison des électeurs et
pour les électeurs les plus jeunes il y
a pas de téléphone à la maison il y a
personne qui répond à des appels des des
numéros inconnus donc
si si c'est tout ce qu'on compte au
niveau des sondages ça veut dire que on
ne peut expliquer que les opinions d'une
certaine instant pourcentage de la
population et puis la deuxième chose que
ça indique c'est que on a on voit que le
trumpisme c'est quelque chose qui qui
est très populaire au sein du parti
républicain mais pas du tout populaire
dans la population américaine donc on
voit un parti qui devient de plus en
plus extrémiste et puis un électorat qui
ne suit pas ce parti dans cette
direction Alexandre Mandel vous pouvez
peut-être réagir à ce que vient de dire
Christian andle est-ce que on est c'est
révélateur d'une sorte de limite du
trumpisme ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
il finit par se recentrer on a entendu
pendant la campagne des gens pour une
fois alors oui certes beaucoup de
candidats avaient besoin du soutien de
Trump mais on a aussi entendu des
castiques du parti républicain comme
lindsegram dire ce serait quand même pas
mal que il adoucisse son temps c'est
commencé déjà pendant la campagne a
critiquer Trump ce qui était quand même
relativement nouveau je pense que le
parti républicain aujourd'hui est
parfaitement consciente des limites
n'ont pas du trumpisme parce que les
thèmes restent populaires aux États-Unis
mais des limites de Trump j'ai envie de
dire de la communication des des
des ennuis judiciaires qui qui
s'accumulent pour lui qui fatigue alors
peut-être pas tellement les républicains
qui le soutiennent à 70% mais qui
fatigue notamment les électeurs
indépendants qui je le rappelle puisque
on peut il faut aux États-Unis se
déclarer soit démocrate soit
républicains soit indépendants ils sont
quand même 41% de de la totalité des
gens en âge de voté et cela ils sont
déjà fatigués du trumpisme du trumpisme
ça date de 2015 ça ça aura 9 ans 10 ans
quasiment au moment de l'élection 2024
c'est c'est un temps extrêmement long
aux États-Unis en politique Cécile
c'est effectivement cette espèce de
plafond qu'aurait atteint le trumpy
c'est ce que montre un peu ce scrutin ou
est-ce que finalement ce sont les thèmes
comme le droit à l'avortement qui
finalement ont été plus on a un impact
plus important pour justement le vote
démocrate il y a un peu des deux en fait
dans ces maîtresse ces élections de
mi-mandat l'ancien président Trump c'est
investi de manière tout à fait
extraordinaire en investissant en
adoubant littéralement puisque
l'expression était d'aller baiser à nos
papas et parfois le l'ancien président a
utilisé le verbe embrasser d'une manière
encore un petit peu plus vulgaire que
cela mais il s'agissait vraiment
d'investir des candidats qui auraient sa
marque de fabrique et ses candidats ont
plutôt déçu à tel en scène qu'il a
distribué très peu de compliments
l'année dernière en disant bon si les
candidats réussissent aux élections je
prendrai le crédit et puis s'ils
échouent ce sera de leur faute donc il y
a effectivement des limites du trumpisme
que les classiques dont parler monsieur
Mendel était tout à fait conscient mais
il y a aussi on le voit quand on
dépouille les résultats des référendums
dans différents États comme par exemple
le Kentucky de la part des électeurs
conservateurs un souhait de ne pas avoir
dans la Constitution une clause qui
interdise le droit à l'avortement et en
même temps on est dit une gouverneur qui
était la porte-parole la première
porte-parole de du gouvernement Trump
serait happy Sanders et donc c'est plus
compliqué que cela les stratèges
démocrates ce sont dit que c'était pas
forcément une très bonne idée de mettre
en avant le droit à l'avortement comme
une comme une thématique de campagne qui
est vraiment devrait faire basculer les
électorat et finalement ça a réussi à
mobiliser plus que ce que disait les
sondages près pré-élection de poésie
alors on sait que vous êtes spécialisé
aux politiques sur ce plateau mais
peut-être avez-vous voulu vous rebondir
simplement sur ce les enseignements
qu'on peut tirer de ce scrutin
je crois qu'il y a deux choses la
première c'est si on fait des
comparaisons historiques on pensait que
en 2022 se répèterait 2010 ou 2018
c'est-à-dire que le parti au pouvoir
perdrait largement les élections de
mi-manda or ce que nous voyons c'est
qu'il y a une partie de 2020 qui s'est
reproduite c'est-à-dire une mobilisation
très forte des jeunes des femmes des
noirs sans doute on verra dans le détail
des résultats qui traduit en fait un
rejet de Trump et de ses candidats il
mobilise de son côté mais il mobilise
contre lui et ces personnes ce qui fait
que on a dit au départ étudier
économiste aucun parti au pouvoir ne
peut gagner avec 8,2% d'inflation et
bien ils n'ont pas vraiment perdu en
dépit de ses résultats économiques cat
parce que il y avait la question
sociétale l'avortement et il y avait
aussi la défense de la démocratie un
certes finalement on a dit cet
argumentaire de Biden n'allait pas
fonctionner peut-être quand on regardera
avec un peu plus de calme et de distance
les résultats on se dira qu'il a
fonctionné cet argumentaire car il a
mobilisé contre Trump et c'est plus
fidèles aficionados une partie de gens
qui n'aurait pas été votée au mittorm
Christian Allah vous êtes d'accord avec
ce que vient de dire domiquement easy on
ne connaît pas en fait le contenu on
sait qu'il y a une forte taux de
participation mais me semble-t-il on
connaît pas vraiment le détail c'est
est-ce que les femmes se sont beaucoup
mobilisées est-ce que les jeunes se sont
beaucoup mobilisés on le suppose mais
est-ce qu'on peut en être sûr
on verra dans les jours les semaines à
venir certainement je suis complètement
d'accord mais
les résultats et la différence entre les
résultats et les réponses au sondage ça
indique que les jeunes que les femmes
que les noirs que tous les populations
qui se sentaient menacées par le
trumpisme ont été mobilisés pendant
cette élection
on voit que parmi beaucoup de
d'électeurs dans ce pays
on a agi on a réagi si vous voulez à
cause de cette peur créée par le
trumpisme la décision de la Cour suprême
de limiter le droit de à l'avortement et
donc oui ça va prendre des jours et des
semaines à analyser complètement mais
c'est vrai que ça expliquerait peut-être
la grande différence entre les réponses
qu'on vient de voir au sondage et puis
les résultats qu'on voit aujourd'hui on
va retrouver Julie dungelhof est-elle là
ou pas parce que
je ne sais plus
Julie est-ce que vous m'entendez je suis
là en direct donc d'Atlanta on vous
retrouve donc vous faisiez justement un
point sur la sénatoriale puisqu'il est
donc on le disait il va y avoir un
second tour en Géorgie second tour qui
sera évidemment fondamental pour
déterminer la couleur de la chambre
haute puisque pour l'instant on est dans
l'égalité parfaite au Sénat
oui tout à fait on se retrouve dans une
situation assez similaire à liée à deux
ans ou la Géorgie avait été
quand ça veut pas ça veut pas pardon
Julie est Parton hôtels spectateur
Alexandre Mendel peut-être est-ce qu'on
peut rebondir justement sur cette
question géorgienne d'ailleurs la
couleur puisqu'on est à égalité pour
l'instant kamalahari c'est tant la
présidente ça veut dire qu'on se
retrouver dans le même scénario le Sénat
resterait plutôt démocrate mais après
pour les journalistes et les Américains
parce que la Géorgie a un mode de
scrutin qui ressemble d'ailleurs un peu
aux nôtre ou si vous faites pas 50% plus
une voix vous avez le droit un deuxième
tour seulement il y a pas lieu dans une
semaine il a lieu le 6 décembre
qui est présidente de fait de même des
yurets en tant que vice-présidente des
États-Unis du Sénat qui fera basculer
d'un côté ou de l'autre le Sénat alors
il y en a en tout cas qui a scruté ces
élections c'est bien sûr vous le dix
meilleurs Zena ski le président Ukrain
qui avait appelé d'ailleurs hier à
l'unité puisque un certain nombre de
républicains ont dit qu'ils étaient
moins enclins à aider l'Ukraine le
Kremlin a réagi aujourd'hui à ces
élections américaines en disant que les
relations entre Moscou et Washington
resteront mauvaises quel que soit le
résultat des élections de mi-mandat à
souligner en tout cas la présidente
russe vous voyez donc s'afficher les
propos de Dimitri pescoff Dominique
Moïse le Congrès a priori a déjà
débloqué quoi 40 milliards de dollars
pour soutenir l'Ukraine est-ce que
aujourd'hui que la Chambre des
Représentants passe bascule quand même
côté républicain est-ce qu'on peut dire
que l'aide à l'Ukraine est menacé
oui mais il faut pas aller trop loin la
victoire
républicaine
et pour le moins modéré
si le Sénat reste du côté démocrate on
peut dire qu'il ne se sera pas passé
énormément de choses et
au moment où les Américains votaient ils
se passait quelque chose de considérable
sur un plan symbolique et stratégique en
Ukraine avec le fait que les troupes
russes quittent la ville de Kerson donc
c'est un argumentaire fantastique pour
le président Biden qui peut dire aux
Américains vous trouvez que l'aide est
lourde mais regardez elle est efficace
ça marche les Russes se retirent ce
n'est pas de l'argent dépensé en vain
vous avez aidé le peuple craignant et ça
se voit sur les cartes et ça se voit
dans les esprits et en même temps
oui peut-être quand on est quelqu'un
d'éduquer à New York etc les lecteurs du
Kansas qui fait son plein et qui
constate que ces 50% plus cher que sous
Trump de mettre de l'essence dans le
dans son pick-up V8 lui se fiche pas mal
de l'Ukraine dont il en a dont il
entendait même pas parler il y a encore
un an donc c'est bien les bons
sentiments mais je pense aussi que non
non non non
je pense aussi que alors vous dites oui
les républiciers ça menace etc que
demande les républicains finalement ils
demandent que les comptes soient
affectés qui est finalement un petit peu
pour résumer grossièrement avec une
image une note de frais
je sais pas si dans l'histoire
américaine il y a eu beaucoup comme ça
de chèques en blanc fait pour des
gouvernements étrangers pour acheter
voilà sans retour sur
[Musique]
je ne veux rien dire je parle pas de
bons sentiments mais regardez la
deuxième guerre mondiale si on avait
demandé aux Américains qu'est-ce que et
bien à la fin on aurait vu le 6 juin
vous avez tout à fait raison de mettre
l'accent sur la dimension matérielle sur
le fait que les lecteurs américains il
ne se loin pas nécessairement de
l'Ukraine mais il ne s'agit pas là de
bons sentiments il s'agit de bonnes
stratégies ces îles coquet mon coco un
mot peut-être là-dessus j'ai vu que
Marjorie telor green qui a été donc
réélu en Géorgie elle avait été
totalement contre justement c'était de
l'Ukraine il faut voilà les cruns c'est
loin c'est un peu son argument et puis
Kevin McCarthy donc le chef des
républicains à la Chambre qui a priori
devrait prendre la présidence de la
Chambre lui a parlé justement on ne fera
pas de chèques en blanc donc ça va être
une vraie question tout de même oui il
s'agit de voir si la rhétorique qui
prévalait pendant la guerre froide va
continuer à être valable pour les
Américains à se représenter comme le
camp de la démocratie contre la barbarie
du reste du monde je pourrais aussi
rappeler mais mes collègues le savent
très bien que en pleine guerre du
Vietnam 75% des Américains ne savaient
pas situer le pays non plus c'était
toujours loin et le système qui était
une quasi conscription
était quand même très très mal perçu et
malgré tout le président Nixon parvenait
à se représenter comme comme quelqu'un
de wilsonien qui allait amener la paix
dans le monde Christian anley vous
pensez qu'effectivement c'est menacé
c'était de à l'Ukraine
avec justement la victoire des
républicains non à la chambre
ben forcément il faut pas aller trop
loin parce que même si on a Kevin
Mercury et d'autres républicains
trumpistes qui pendant leur campagne
disait aux électeurs que c'est la fin de
notre soutien pour le peuple ukrainien
il y a quand même des des
traditionnalistes au sein du parti
républicains comme mais tu me connais
d'autres
qui vont toujours soutenir nos
partenaires en Europe et le peuple
ukrainien face
à cette agression de la part de la
Russie et donc on va voir
une différence entre
ce que disait les candidats républicains
et ce que va faire ce qu'ils vont faire
dans le Sénat et le concret après le 20
janvier alors justement si ça change
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer d'après un
sondage Chicago Cancé dans le Globe
lefears bon j'ai vu qu'une grande
majorité des Américains approuvaient
approuvent le soutien à l'Ukraine deux
tiers des républicains ce serait quand
même favorable à l'envoi d'arbres donc
c'est loin mais bon les sondages encore
une fois c'est vrai qu'ils sont pas
forcément fiables mais en tout cas eux
disent que les Américains sont plus
favorables en même temps ils sont
abreuvés c'est incroyable d'information
sur l'Ukraine mais c'est incroyable en
tant que c'est dans un fossé boom
ciennen fait une coupure on n'oserait
même pas ça en France et puis par
ailleurs il y a une culture quand même
aux États-Unis depuis la guerre froide
très antirrus très ancrée dans
l'imaginaire américain du méchant
pardon de la référence mais du méchant
qui va combat Rocky dans Rocky 4 c'est
mais c'est réellement ça c'est
réellement ça alors il y a 11 milliards
de dollars encore qui restent à
approuver ou est-ce que ça a été
approuvé
en fait le meilleur atout
de Biden et deux Hélène ski c'est
Vladimir Poutine lui-même c'est à dire
qu'il est très difficile de dire
cette propagande anti russe est
insupportable quand on voit
Vladimir Poutine se transformer chaque
jour davantage on a leader toujours plus
dictatorial et plus les résultats sur le
terrain de la Russie seront difficiles
plus on pense que il y aura un risque
d'escalade
pendant la campagne tant qu'il était
juste un dirigeant autoritaire ça
pouvait encore aller maintenant qu'il a
l'étiquette criminelle de guerre c'est
emmerdant même pour les trumpistes
le temps ne pas défavorable tout le même
mais c'est d'ailleurs il a peur
parce que la guerre est longue et le
temps n'est pas forcément favorable aux
Ukrainiens quand il s'agit de mettre la
main au portefeuille c'est toujours
pareil
oui
il y a beaucoup d'Américains qui
maintenant qui des électeurs qui
souffrent et qui pensent à leur propre
portefeuille et on part aux alliés ou
même aux
Ukrainiens à l'autre bout du monde c'est
vrai mais en même temps
je vois qu'il y a des gens dans les deux
parties des leaders qui malgré tout
malgré la propagande
consommée par les électeurs républicains
qui est vraiment pro russe protéines et
anti-ukraine
qu'il y aura toujours cette ce soutien
pour le peuple ukrainien surtout quand
on voit comment on voit aujourd'hui les
troupes russes qui sont en train de de
quitter Carson et on voit des résultats
sur le terrain donc même s'il y a ce
crainte cette peur
je crois que le soutien
même après ces élections l'autre grand
dossier Cécile c'est l'Iran sur la
politique étrangère à l'égard de l'Iran
les négociations ont repris mais on sait
que c'est sans succès est-ce qu'il a il
risque d'y avoir une inflexion
ça vraiment ça va dépendre beaucoup
aussi de l'élection ou non de Keven
McCarter comme speaker donc dirigeant de
la majorité républicaine qui se dessine
à la Chambre des Représentants il n'est
pas évident que les républicains parlent
d'une seule voix sur ce genre de
question et également au Sénat la
commission qui est dédiée aux Affaires
étrangères va devoir aussi marquer sa
position mais il est clair que l'Iran
apparaît comme un méchant pratiquement à
égalité avec les Russes très certaine de
mémoriser est-ce que ça va changer
est-ce que ça va est-ce que la politique
de Biden va être plus dure à l'égard de
l'Iran en sachant justement que la
Chambre des Représentants sera dominée
par les républicains
je crois pas qu'il fallait poser pardon
la question ainsi
la réalité c'est que le régime iranien
se bat pour sa survie pour la première
fois depuis 1979 et dans ce contexte il
doit faire le choix est-ce que en étant
plus dur je rallie un peu plus de
population iranienne derrière moi à
partir d'un nationalisme qui se demeure
les Saoudiens mettaient en avant il y a
quelques jours les risques d'attaque
iranienne contre eux simplement pour
détourner l'attention du peuple dans une
nouvelle guerre donc le point de départ
de cette question il est atterrant il
n'est pas à Washington les Américains en
cours justement dans le cadre mais c'est
négociations elle dépendent beaucoup
plus de l'évolution de la politique
intérieure iranienne que de l'évolution
de la politique intérim donc pas de
américain
Alexandre Mandel oui c'est intéressant
parce que
c'est pareil bon je parle de résultats
d'élection et je est-ce que ce genre de
très importantes choses ont vraiment
intéressé les lecteurs américains moi je
crois pas du tout
c'est
sur les questions ah oui est-ce que si
les républicains auront une politique
étrangères tellement différentes des
démocrates il reste quand même pas mal
de républicains qui partagent les
sentiments néo conservateurs de
démocrates interventionniste finalement
moi je vois pas trop de différence
j'écoute Lindsey Graham j'ai pas le
sentiment que d'ailleurs un ancien
copain de Joe Biden j'ai pas le
sentiment qui est tellement différent
sur la politique étrangère
ça va être intéressant parce que Biden
pourra sur ce sujet trouver je pense des
consensus avec les républicains dit
modérés qui partagent le même sentiment
globalement de de d'un accord à minima
avec les Iraniens une politique un peu
dure à l'égard des non parce qu'on se
souvient quand même Donald Trump a été
sorti hein du traité c'est la raison
pour laquelle je pose la question tout
de même quoi il est sorti du traité
ensuite il y a eu des reprises de
négociations parce que byden a été élu
donc mais ça n'a pas fonctionné jusqu'à
présent et et le principal obstacle
c'était les Iraniens mais mais pour
prolonger ce que ce que vous dites et je
suis tout à fait d'accord il y a pas sur
les grandes questions
de différence majeure
entre républicains et démocrate sur les
grands sujets de politique étrangère
de Trump il y avait quand même sur les
grands sujets internationaux que ce soit
en tout cas le climat et l'Iran il y a
une vraie différence oui mais
le climat
c'est évident mais le climat a été le
grand absent de la campagne des pour les
mimandes on en a pas parlé et c'est même
profondément choquant très intéressant
dans le Washington Post disons que chez
les électeurs la question climatique
arriver même chez les jeunes ils ont
imaginons que les jeunes soient plus
concernés en quatrième ou cinquième
position des préoccupations donc ce
n'est pas une préoccupation aux
États-Unis mais de l'électeur démocrate
comme de l'électeur républicain sauf en
Californie ou les conséquences
et plus importants
qui a été adopté cet été 400 milliards
de dollars dans la technologie verte
mais c'est vrai que le climat ne faisait
pas du tout partie de cette campagne
mais est-ce que Joe Biden va rester donc
sur cette ligne
je crois que oui et c'est triste qu'on
avait tant de problèmes domestiques dans
ce pays pendant ces élections que le
climat
a été placé en quatrième ou cinquième
pour place mais je crois que même avec
des sièges pris par les républiques les
républicains pardonnez-moi que Joe Biden
sera toujours
à leader
quand on climat même avec
on a vu plusieurs étapes beaucoup de
négociations entre les démocrates de
gauche et Joe Mansion de la Virginie
occidentale et d'autres
conservateurs des modérés afin de
produire un projet de loi qui allait
faire quelque chose au moins pour le
climat ce qui est un sujet ici dans ce
pays qui est toujours
pour laquelle il y a toujours beaucoup
de division entre les électeurs des deux
parties malheureusement donc
effectivement oui jobiden suivra cette
même ligne je crois beaucoup quelque
soit leur étiquette qui sont des élus de
territoire qui produisent du charbon
soit qui extrait du pétrole soit qui
feront de la
de la fracturation hydraulique c'est
compliqué aussi vous parliez de Manching
qui est un un sénateur de Virginie
occidentale démocrate mais qui pour le
coup sur les questions climatiques votre
systématiquement du côté des
républicains puisque lui représente un
État producteur de charbon donc les
divisions effectivement sont liées aussi
aux intérêts des uns et des autres
directions la résona tout de suite on va
retrouver Loïc piala notre envoyé
spécial l'Arizona c'est pas encore les
jeux ne sont pas encore fait en Arizona
66% des bulletins de vote dépouillés on
attendait des élections serrées elles le
sont ni à seulement qu'un demi point
d'écart entre Cathy hops la démocrate et
kerykla la République pour le poste de
gouverneur carry Lake qui ont beaucoup
parlé pendant cette campagne c'est une
sorte de clone de Donald Trump elle
paraît assez confiante sur son compte
Twitter elle a annoncé que la victoire
allait être large c'est à vérifier qu'il
y a vous parliez de l'équilibre au Sénat
évidemment une course qui est suivie de
très près ici l'élection sénatoriale qui
oppose marquelly le sénateur sortant
démocrate ancien astronaute ancien
pilote de chasse très populaire marié
une femme extraordinaire comment
courageuse qui avait été victime d'une
fusillade et puis en face à un
républicain black master s'investisseur
de la Silicon Valley qui est peut-être
le plus modéré des républicains en lice
lors de cette élection Marc Élie a une
avance de 5 points c'est déjà plus
significatif que Katia dans la course au
poste de gouverneur mais c'est avant
celle pourrait fondre parce que et bien
les les bulletins de vote qui reste à
compter pour beaucoup d'entre eux
concernent des zones des régions des
circonscriptions traditionnellement
républicaines on n'aura pas de résultats
à définitifs probablement pas avant
cette journée la fin de cette journée de
mercredi peut-être même encore il faudra
qu'il faudra encore attendre jeudi donc
une course et une élection ici très
serrée pour le poste de gouverneur pour
le poste de sénateurs également pour le
poste de secrétaire d'État c'est
important parce qu'ici le secrétaire
d'État en Arizona c'est LUI ou ELLE qui
supervise les élections et Mark finition
le candidat républicain avait annoncé
lui qu'il n'aurait pas certifié la
victoire de Joe Biden en 2020 et que il
changera sans doute ou qu'il essaiera de
changer les règles électorales pour 2024
pour la prochaine élections a toujours
en ballotage on va la scruter on va
scruter cet état évidemment de près
pendant les 24 heures qui viennent merci
beaucoup Loïc Loïc piala donc en direct
de cet état il y a tout de même eu des
figures républicaines qui se sont un peu
imposées lors de ce scrutin celle
notamment de Ron De Santis réélu
gouverneur de Floride il pourrait être
un rival de Donald Trump dit-on à la
présidentielle de 2024 son portrait
un nouveau triomphe pour Ron 206 à 44
ans cet ancien militaire perd de trois
enfants est largement réélu à la tête du
quatrième étage le plus riche d'Amérique
nous avons embrassé la liberté nous
avons maintenu la loi et l'ordre
protéger les droits des parents et
respecter nos contribuables
aujourd'hui après 4 ans au pouvoir le
peuple a rendu son verdict la liberté
reste en Floride
un discours offensif pour celui qui
incarne la nouvelle droite dure à
l'américaine pour fondeur de ce qu'il
nomme l'idéologie walk Rhône De Santis
mène depuis plusieurs années une
bataille culturelle de tous les instants
avec les démocrates illustration de ce
combat contre le prétendu endoctrinement
des enfants en 2021 lorsqu'ils signent
une loi interdisant l'enseignement des
sujets en lien avec l'orientation
sexuelle des convictions assez proches
de celles de Donald Trump mais sur la
forme ronde de Santis se démarque de
l'ancien président son image de père de
famille et son style posé le rendent
moins clivant preuve de la rivalité
croissante entre les deux hommes Donald
Trump plat a publié pendant la campagne
d'un surnom peu flatteur
nous sommes en train de gagner très très
largement pour la nomination du parti
républicain comme personne ne l'a jamais
vu
regardez Trump est à 71% et rendent la
morale à 10% grâce à sa réélection Ron
De Santis peut espérer participer à la
primaire républicaine en vue de la
présidentielle de 2024 une possibilité
guerre appréciée par Donald Trump
désireux de se projeter au plus vite
vers la reconquête de la Maison Blanche
est-ce qu'il est effectivement un
challenger possible manifestement selon
un sondage sorti des ions de CNN rentre
de Santis et préférée à Trump par les
républicains surtout par les
républicains de son propre état il a été
très efficace dans la communication avec
l'électorat latino américain en
particulier puisqu'il y a une forte
communauté cubaine américaine qui a
véritablement intégré le message
politique du parti républicain selon
lequel les démocrates et Bridge en
particulier sont des communistes donc il
reste à voir si ce type de message va
correspondre aux autres latinos
américains la communauté est loin d'être
monolithique mais effectivement ça donne
une occasion aux américains qui ne sont
pas emballés par la personnalité de
Trump et qui estime peut-être qu'il ne
donne pas assez de résultats dans son
modèle d'avoir quelqu'un d'autre une
solution alternative solution
alternative de dire qu'il a été rendu
populaire de Santis par ces gestion du
covid ont testé enfin la Floride était
quand même un des rares sinon le seul
État où tout était ouvert
et ça et
moi oui mais alors attendez réellement
on peut regarder les chiffres finalement
pas tellement différemment que de que
d'autres États donc il est vu plutôt
comme quelqu'un qui a préservé son
économie et qui a pas eu un bilan cicaté
catastrophique certes mais pas aussi
catastrophique qu'on l'aurait imaginé
donc dans l'esprit des des républicains
qui soutiennent De Santis a été un peu
un sauveur quelqu'un qui avait une voix
différente pendant le pendant la gestion
du covid de manière très intéressante
les bookmakers le mettent maintenant en
tête de celui qui gagnera les carrément
l'élection présidentielle 2024
aujourd'hui si vous voulez parier
aujourd'hui
mais bon en tout cas Donald Trump a payé
son dernier mot Dominique Moïse il
devrait peut-être annoncer sa
candidature mardi prochain
je crois que la course à la présidence
ne va pas être un long fleuve tranquille
pour Donald Trump
la résistance s'organise contre lui à
l'extérieur du parti et à l'intérieur du
parti et en fait ce qui est intéressant
c'est que nous jugeons Rome De Santis
comme plus modéré car il laisse sur la
forme mais il est beaucoup plus
idéologue que ne l'a jamais été d'un
instrument la seule idéologie de Donald
Trump c'est elysée moi il y a un
narcissisme qui
insinnise et totale lui il joue vraiment
on a l'impression qu'il croit à ce qu'il
dit et en même temps il passe mieux et
la différence majeure
c'est l'âge si en 2024 vous avez un
candidat de 46 ans car il aura 46 ans
contre un candidat de 82 ans Joe Biden
ce sera difficile pour baiden là pour le
coup il apparaîtra vraiment
que Bayonne sera candidat en justement
c'est une question
à priori il avait dit si Trump se
présente je me présente il me semble
qu'il avait dit ça
oui donc on voit que le président de
Paris tant de démocrates même il y a
deux ans qui qui croyaient que c'était
un candidat trop vieux pour devenir
président des États-Unis mais on voit
après deux ans un président très
efficace qui a réussi à
travailler très effectivement avec les
membres de son parti dans le concret et
donc il y a vraiment pas de raison pour
laquelle il faut changer de candidat
pour 2024 malgré cela
malgré son âge
malgré son âge moi personnellement j'ai
mes opinions mais si on parle de
l'analyse de de son travail
à la Maison Blanche depuis deux ans on
voit un président qui qui a fait presque
tout ce que voulait
les membres les plus loyaux de son parti
que ce soit les modérés ou les
progressifs donc
pour beaucoup la démocrate en ce moment
il y a pas de de il y a pas besoin de
changer de candidat pour donner en face
de lui il avait quelqu'un comme de santé
justement beaucoup plus jeune
c'est une très bonne question mais pour
des sentis il faut dire comme tu disais
tout à l'heure un autre invité que c'est
quelqu'un qui qui est vraiment au même
niveau de de notre arme quand à son
idéologie
même s'il est moins vulgaire et même
s'il est plus sincère dans ce qu'il dit
mais c'est toujours quelqu'un de
l'extrême droite c'est quelqu'un qui qui
vient de dans son dernier discours
parler de de la Floride comme si c'était
une un état dans lequel
la vérité ne comptait plus un saute de
d'État à part ou
l'idéologie
démocrate n'a pas de place dans la
société donc c'est toujours un trampiste
même si les plus jeunes et un peu moins
vulgaire il est aussi dans le spectacle
si on se souvient quand même il y a
quelques mois il avait renvoyé des
immigrés en attente de papier des
immigrés qui étaient pas tout à fait
illégaux mais de papier à martas
wagnarde qui est une île très chic
d'un nouvel Angleterre où vivent
notamment les Obama qui ont une maison
donc il est aussi dans le spectacle la
communication et les a renvoyés en avion
là-bas et il a dit moi je m'en
débarrasse Victorine
ça reste les États-Unis il faut aussi un
peu de spectacle politique vous diriez
qu'il est d'extrême droite Cécile coquin
mococo rentre de Santis je dirais pas ça
parce que le terme a des connotations en
France et en Europe en général qui sont
pas du tout les mêmes qu'aux États-Unis
il reste à voir vraiment si il va rester
intéressant stratégiquement pour les
républicains de caresser dans le sens du
poil la base évangélique et c'est
vraiment ça qui va être très intéressant
à observer dans l'évolution de ce parti
et de ses choix lui-même est-il
religieux ou pas
religieux oui oui plus que
après quant à la sincérité des candidats
très franchement moi j'y crois plus
depuis
primaire je rappelle que les primaires
auront lieu les premières en février
2024 mais les premiers débats des
primaires républicaines c'est dès cet
été dès cet été si Trump se déclare
candidat il sera obligé d'aller dans les
fameux débats où ils sont 8 à 10
personnes et tout
ne rivaliserait pas sur les moyens
financiers
si mais je veux dire c'est quand même
une sacrée indication et ça elle se sera
intéressant à suivre sur 26 combien il
va pouvoir lever encore parce que si
c'est la personnalité émergente vous y
avoir ce qu'ils appellent des packs
c'est à dire des des grands financiers
des grandes entreprises qui vont donner
de l'argent qui s'il le voit comme la
personnalité émergente
pour poursuivre sur ce que vous dites il
y a une dynamique et cette dynamique qui
vient de s'enclencher avec les résultats
partiels des élections de mi-mandat il
me semble qu'elle joue tout à la fois
contre Donald Trump et contre Joba Eden
si je devais faire aujourd'hui un pari
je dirais qu'en 2024 les élections
n'opposeront ni Biden ni Donald Trump
Christian manifestement sur ce plateau
c'est ce qu'on a l'air de dire c'est
place aux jeunes un petit peu enfin aux
jeunes en tout cas au moins vieux vous
pensez vous à un duel encore Biden Trump
en 2024
personnellement j'espère que non
certainement mais c'est quand même c'est
possible on
va avoir la semaine prochaine comme vous
voulez de dire que dans notre rampe
annoncer quelque chose ça candidature
pour 2024
mais oui je crois qu'il y a des
Américains que que ce soit des
républicains des démocrates des
indépendants qui qui n'ont aucune envie
de revoir cette spectacle pour une
deuxième fois en 2024 donc là on a envie
finalement aux États-Unis et en revoir
le spectacle
Biden mais juste un dernier mot
Christian
on a beaucoup parlé des bébés Trump même
si l'expression franchement mais en tout
cas en 2006 on a vu que c'était à double
tranchant mais chez les démocrates il y
a Kamala à risque kamalahari on en parle
plus
c'est un potentiel quand même potentiel
oui bien sûr mais le problème pour les
républicains c'est qu'il y a vraiment
un ou deux chefs du parti des leaders
dans le parti tandis que dans notre
partie il y a tant de candidats
potentiels par exemple et bien sûr mais
aussi bienvenue sur timbray and beaucoup
d'autres leaders de toute région du pays
que ce soit des centristes ou des
progressistes
qui sont valables en 2024 donc que ce
soit Biden ou quelqu'un qui est que vous
venez de dire moins âgés
j'espère qu'on aura des débats très
intéressants 2018
est-ce qu'un Bill Clinton peut sortir du
camp démocrate c'est la grande question
merci
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
Alexandre Mandel merci beaucoup Cécile
coquet mon coco d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous Christian anneley merci à
Julie denguellof et puis merci aussi à
Loïc qui était avec ton direct de
l'Arizona merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis et restez avec nous sur
France 24
[Musique]